tense moments in the skies over Northern
California a small plane with four
people on board had to make an emergency
landing Friday the flight bound from
Idaho Falls to a small airport in San
Jose was instead forced to land at San
Jose's Mineta International Airport all
without the help of the planes landing
gear San Jose two or three three or four
live alpha we're gonna have to build
Atlantis the pilot of this single-engine
plane making the gutsy call to bring it
in for a rough landing after alerting
the control tower he couldn't use the
planes landing gear the pilot asked
ground crews for help for Lima Roger we
can pass Emily the plane circled the San
Jose International Airport for over an
hour to lighten the fuel load finally
with all airport traffic halted and the
runway cleared the pilot brought the
plane down on its belly
eventually skidding to a stop four
people were on board at the time
including the pilot certainly the pilot
I'm told was significantly yes
choking up as a result to this but my
hat goes off to the pilot for the time
he took to prepare for that landing a
similar scene played out last week in
Daytona Beach Florida
a small non-commercial plane made a hard
belly landing showering the runway with
sparks causing a fire video captured by
a witness shows no landing or nose gear
in sight in both cases everyone on board
walked away unharmed I look at those and
I think of Sully makes you appreciate
how talented some of these pilots